[Music]
in 2023 the Famous Five Nights at
Freddy's game series were finally
brought to the movies and proved to be a
resounding success with a budget of just
$20 million the first movie generated
nearly $300 million worldwide the
biggest hit that producer bloomhouse has
ever had so it's absolutely clear that
the whole project will be continued find
out all about the current progress of
Five Nights at Freddy's 2 in this video
just like its predecessor the horror
film will be based on the video game
series of the same name by indie game
developer Scott cin part one introduced
us to the story of Mike Schmidt who is
hired as a night security guard in a
rundown Diner when he learns that the
puppets there contain The Souls of dead
children he has to fear for his
life although the first movie was not at
all well received by critics fans were
mostly pleased accordingly reactions
were positive when lead actor Josh
Hutcherson officially confirmed at the
beginning of January that work on part
two had already begun exactly what the
plot of Five Nights at Freddy's 2 is
going to be like is not yet known
however there are already some Clues and
theories as to where the journey could
take us director Emma Tammy stated in an
interview with variety that the
subsequent films couldn't very well be
based on the individual parts of the
video game series as a result rumors
have been circulating that revolve
around Mike's brother Garrett Garrett
soul is said to reside in balloon boy a
character who first appeared in the
second part of the games and provided
plenty of scares we are definitely
expecting the introduction of a bunch of
new characters anyway in fact another
character is already announced at the
end of the first movie in the closing
credits a distorted voice spells out a
series of letters that make up the
phrase come find me shortly before this
the song My Grandfather's Clock is
played a Melody that die hard fans will
already be familiar with in the games
this melody fends off one of the
nastiest villains in the entire Five
Nights at Freddy's Universe called the
puppet it is an animatronic that is
possessed by the the spirit of a
murdered girl the introduction of the
puppet as a possible antagonist in part
two could build a connection to the
video game and it's likely to excite
fans so far there's been no official
confirmation of the cast of Five Nights
at Freddy's 2 though some of the names
are as good as certain it can be
strongly assumed that a number of the
previous actors will return for the
sequel first and foremost Josh
Hutcherson who was already impressive in
part one as the main character Mike we
can also expect to see Piper Rubio as
Abby Elizabeth L as Vanessa and Mary
Stewart Masterson as Aunt Jane besides
the familiar cast some influencers
should also be featured again this time
Mark Fishback AKA Markiplier who was not
involved in part one due to scheduling
conflicts will finally be part of the
cast director Tammy also confirmed that
this time Matthew Lillard will play a
much bigger role as Steve Raglin his
character development is to take place
over the course of three
films initial rumors suggest that
filming on Five Nights at Freddy's 2
will be begin this year meaning that a
release in 2025 would be feasible Emma
Tammy will once again assume her
position as director one thing is
certain though part two is also likely
to be a big challenge for the director
since the fan base is huge and anything
but easy to please especially when it
comes to
details how do you like Five Nights at
Freddy's did the movie live up to your
expectations and what would you love to
see in part two let us know in the
comments
[Music]